hey guys my name is Jess McDowell and
this is a top 5 show not to be confused
with my other top something sure because
this one's about news speaking of news
here's some for your facehole first up
Microsoft is weighing in on the
resolution war and they're challenging
people to spot their differences on
screens more than 60 inches Microsoft
marketing exec and certainly the
marketing exec with the coolest name
ever Harvey eagle has said that gamers
would have trouble seeing differences in
resolutions and frame rates whether
screen more than 60 inches nonetheless
he did acknowledge that the ps4 is a
more powerful console than Microsoft's
Xbox one which is something they need to
overcome although readings
differentiators like exclusive content
can give Marcus off the console or mega
invigorating the hearts of fighter fans
everywhere is the news that tekken 7 is
go bandai namco have announced that the
game is coming and will be powered by
Unreal Engine 4 series director
katsuhiro harada and the tekken dev team
are working with the Epic Games engine
group in Japan on the game the fighter
was leaked a tad early when attack and 7
logo flashed across one of the
protection monitors at evo earlier this
week apparently vr is bad news or at
least that's according to kayvyun decent
about contractor who worked on their be
our room project so why Jason's
cumulative 12 months with the technology
has led him to claim that it is in his
words fundamentally anti-social
completing with the sad trajectory of
entertainment moving further and further
away from shared social experiences well
ouch he also claims he isn't a fan of
online gaming which leads him to dislike
Vyasa since he says it's set to be a
gateway to the ultimate MMORPG for those
playing at home yes that does seem to
imply that he doesn't see MMO gaming as
a social experience he also commented on
the Facebook acquisition of oculus
saying that VR run by a company who is
navin your details and selling them is
threatening to gain this privacy and
next up a video from 2011 has resurfaced
showing the crisis to protagonist in
third person prepare for nightmares
apparently there's a real good reason
why crisis is strictly first person and
that's because your main character
Alcatraz is a headless and spineless
humanoid creature from a particularly
nasty circle of hell reddit user tayson
Jodhpur stood up the gift from a video
which was originally released by one of
the developers as part of a blog about
CryEngine bits and pieces three years
ago anyway moral of the story is all's
horrifying and creepy in the
behind-the-scenes world of video games
the NPD group of actin figures has
released their sales report for June and
it seems even the xbox one with a price
cut will be quite enough to beat up the
ps4 figures the monthly report which
focuses on physical sales in the US
shows that the ps4 was the top-selling
system in June that makes this the sixth
month in a row that the console has come
out on top the ps4 was also the top
platform for physical software sales
across the new gen platforms luckily for
Nintendo the wii u saw a big sales jump
of two hundred and thirty-three percent
for june year-on-year thanks to mario
kart 8 launch as for game sales the
report showed that watch dogs was the
top seller once again across the
platforms and as for individual
platforms mario kart 8 cross the finish
line first and as for your question of
the day let me know if you think we're
in any danger of virtual reality run by
Facebook or if you're not worried as for
all some things on site this week you
can check out cam's commentary on why
you spent so much on steam sales I
talked about how much i love pc gaming
on the gist and our lovely us co-workers
crack into the destiny beta that is all
the good stuff I've got for you from
this week as always let me know if I
missed out on any of your favorite
stories and once again thanks for
joining me
you